Although crime in England’s capital was
on the decline in the mid-19th century, thanks
in part to the relatively recent formation
of the London Metropolitan Police Force in
1839, fear of crime was a persistent, reoccurring
issue thanks to a few instances of robbery
and murder, and, of course, the news media.
In particular, the so-called “garrotting”
cases, where someone strangles someone else,
often using their arm or a length of wire,
cord, or cloth, seemed to touch the rawest
nerve with the people of London, with the
fear of garrotting reaching a fever-pitch
in the 1860s.
Exactly when enterprising ruffians first realised
that they could increase their odds of successfully
robbing a person dramatically by placing that
person in a chokehold first isn’t clear,
since many crimes back in those days often
went unreported due to a general mistrust
of the police amongst poorer folk.
However, historic letters written by purported
survivors of garrotting sent to various London
newspapers date back to at least 1850.
A popular theory is that the practise was
first thought up by criminals on convict ships,
where guards would often use roughly applied
chokeholds to quickly knock out an aggressive
criminal, hopefully without causing any long
lasting injuries.
It’s believed that this coldly efficient
method of putting someone down was picked
up by criminals who inevitably began using
it in their day-to-day criminal dealings.
The weird thing about garrotting and how widely
it was reported at the time is that it doesn’t
actually appear to have been all that common;
even during the supposed height of the “garrotting
panic of 1862”.
So why the panic?
As it turns out, although garrotting itself
was never a major problem in London, newspapers
from the era positively loved reporting on
it.
This led to the few isolated cases that did
happen being blown way out of proportion and
reported on to such an extent that the people
of London were led to believe the streets
were filled to the brim with roving rabbles
of ruffians armed with lengths of wire.
Newspapers’ coverage of garrotting exploded
in 1862 when an MP called Hugh Pilkington
was strangled and robbed of his watch on his
way home from the House of Commons.
Pilkington survived, but news of the incident
was widely reported on to such an extent that
Parliament pushed through the Security from
Violence Act in 1863.
Under the terms of this new act of Parliament,
criminals convicted of any violent theft could
be punished with “up to 50 lashes” along
with a hefty prison sentence.
Following the attack, the police similarly
became noticeably more heavy-handed, presumably
in an attempt to reassure the public that
they were “doing something” about the
problem.
London’s streets were flooded with plain
clothes police officers; minor crimes, like
pickpocketing, that had previously been punished
with a small fine, suddenly became issues
for the courts.
anti-garrot-collar
Anti-garrotting collar
In an effort to prove that they were stomping
down on garrotting in particular, the police
also began classifying regular robberies and
even drunken brawls as instances of garrotting,
to fudge their numbers.
This is similar to how in the 1930s they would
often list instances of theft as “lost property”
to make it appear as though those crimes didn’t
happen as often as they actually did.
By far the most ridiculous by-product of the
panic were the devices invented to dissuaded
potential garrotters.
Various designs of hulking neck-collars with
large spikes were patented.
A cravat with a blade sewn into the hem (meant
to either cut the attacker’s arm or the
device he was using to strangle you) was also
a thing.
But perhaps the greatest example of the extreme
lengths people went to back then to protect
themselves from garrotting was invented by
gun maker Henry Ball and patented in 1858-
the “Anti-Garrotter Belt Pistol”.
This belt-gun was designed to be worn on the
rear.
If someone was trying to strangle you from
behind, you’d discharge the weapon into
said attacker’s sensitive mid-section.
This not only was a working device, but is
now considered “among the rarest of firearms
curiosa” with only a handful of specimens
known to exist today.
Beyond potentially taking away the ability
of your attacker to have children, it no doubt
also left the person firing it with a nice
sized bruise and subsequent lower back pain.
garrot2Although the press continued to discuss
garrotting all throughout the 1860s, actual
verifiable reports of the crime dried up in
1863 right after a large amount of arrests
were made in response to the passing of the
previously mentioned Security from Violence
Act.
As they do so often when a story reaches its
saturation point, eventually the newspapers
kind of forgot about garrotting and started
reporting on other types of crimes, which
unfortunately for their sales-rates didn’t
cause the same type of public panic…
That is until a few murders in a small region
of London’s East End sent the nation into
yet another panic when Jack the Ripper began
his reign of terror in 1888.
But that’s a story for
another day.